we finally have news on saw X and here
are three takeaways number one this
picture of Tobin Bell this is our first
look at the movie number two the new
release date September 29th it was
previously going to be coming out
October 27th so that's moving it up I'm
gonna have to get my content together a
little bit sooner and number three the
synopsis set between the events of saw
one and two a sick and desperate John
travels into Mexico for a risky and
experimental medical procedure in hopes
of a miracle cure for his cancer only to
discover the entire operation as a scam
to defraud the most vulnerable I am a
little surprised that the main events of
the movie take place between one and two
my previous thought was that there were
going to be flashbacks where we see
earlier stuff because obviously I
already knew that Tobin Bell was going
to be in the movie but I wasn't really
expecting the main events of the movie
to take place in the original saw Saga
maybe this will be like jigsaw where it
still does tie into events happening in
the present I'm going to be a little bit
disappointed if none of these storylines
that we've built up in jigsaw or spiral
are followed up in on this I feel like
it's going to be less likely to be
creating continuity errors if it's
taking place in a different country it's
going to be more of like a standalone
story so let me know in the comments
what do you think about this news are
you excited for saw ax what are your
theories